It turns out that this answer would be negative 6. Let's see why. You might
have thought to multiply these together to get the square root of positive 36
which equals 6. But we know that's not true since 6 is a real number and these
two are imaginary numbers. The product rule does not hold for imaginary
numbers. It only holds for real numbers. This was our product rule, and before
X and Y had to be greater than zero, that was so that we would leave these
radicals for real numbers rather than real numbers. instead of multiplying
these radicans together, let's simplify each one by using our imaginary number
I. So we'll have 2 I here and 3 I for here. Multiplying, we will get 6 I
squared... We can replace this i squared with its corresponding value negative
1. We substitute that in to get times negative 1 which equals negative 6, our
answer.